le ministre des comptes publics face aux
yvelinois gérald darmanin est venu
défendre les mesures budgétaires prévue
pour 2019 comme la poursuite de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
accompagné d'une réforme de la fiscalité
locale en cours de réflexion
sa vieille impôts une égalité entre les
citoyens entre les communes c'est pas la
même chose de recettes fiscales attraper
et à versailles par exemple évidemment
essayer de se spécialiser les fiscalités
par collectivité la tva pour la région
la cg pour le département la commune
plutôt la taxe foncière quand vous vous
êtes propriétaire
c'est un débat que nous vous offrons on
a bien trop congrès des maires de france
aux élus pour que nous puissions
discuter à chaque collectivité sa
recette fiscale l'idée de cette réforme
prévue pour février 2010 9
les élus locaux ont des attentes
précises vis-à-vis de l'état on a engagé
nous depuis plusieurs années des plans
de réduction des dépenses des plans au
cid de recherche d'économies dans tout
de tous les côtés on veut bien si vous
voulez porter cet effort d'économie qui
est un effort d'économie qui porte toute
la nation
mais il faut que l'état lui même à son
niveau fasse des efforts qu'ils soient à
la hauteur des mêmes efforts qui demande
aux communes
autre point dans le projet de loi de
finances 2010 9 la transformation du
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi en baisse de charges pour les
entreprises
nous mettons 20 milliards de
transformation du séisme la fameuse
subvention que l'état versé aux
entreprises en baisse de charge qui ont
fait la baisse structurelle d'impôts et
l'année prochaine par exemple une
entreprise pour embaucher quelqu'un au
smic à 0
plutôt que d'attendre un an donc pour
nous c'est
ça va pas nous faire gagner d'argent ça
va pas nous en faire perdre mais en
terme de gestion d'entreprise c'est plus
intéressant
le gouvernement a jusqu'au mardi 2
octobre 2018 pour déposer le projet de
loi de finances à l'assemblée nationale